avec ses deux filles zagora et nayla et
leur beau par yvan la famille de
nathalie blanchette semblait complète
mais il manquait quelque chose c'est un
projet que j'avais dans mon quart depuis
une bonne vingtaine d'années au début de
la pandémie la famille a finalement
décidé de se lancer dans une nouvelle
aventure devenir famille d'accueil avec
le confinement
de l'année passée avec les enfants à la
maison ben je me dis que ça pourrait
être un beau projet à remettre sur la
table les parents voulaient s'assurer
que tout le monde s'implique dans le
projet les a fait participer au
processus puis on n'a jamais pris aucune
décision sans les entendre
après un processus de sélection qui a
duré quelques mois la famille a
finalement accueilli un premier enfant
en novembre dernier un ajustement pour
les deux petites filles vers des
fichiers photos sur ce que j'avais un
peu peur mais quand est arrivé j'ai
réalisé que c'est correct que ça allait
marcher
il va rester avec nous longtemps on va
pour apprendre à la connaître les
blanches et de bélanger groleau font
partie des treize familles d'accueil qui
se sont ajoutées cette année dans la
capitale nationale
de ce nombre huit sont devenus familles
d'accueil temporaires et cinq se sont
inscrits dans la banque mixte en vue
d'une adoption l'amour qu'à offrir cette
petite famille devrait bientôt se
multiplier le couple a récemment acheté
une plus grosse maison dans le but
d'accueillir jusqu'à quatre enfants en
plus de naïla ils adorent à la maison
qu'on ne présentait pas assez grande
pour recevoir plus qu'une tête une
deuxième personne puis on veut aider des
gens on veut les organiser pour qu'ils
soient bien dans la vie puis poser des
bons moments et ça fera comme beaucoup
de frères et ça beaucoup d'amis et ben
ça va faire plus de personnes pour jouer
à l'image de cette année qui a été un
tourbillon de défis pour bien des gens
la famille est prête à relever celui qui
s'offrira elle dans les prochaines
années nous on est partis avec l'idée
que les enfants qu'on vaut qu'ils vont
nous être présentés ces des enfants qui
ont besoin de nous que nous on a besoin
d'eux ici cassandra nadeau la marche
radio canada québec